- All right, I've got a weak offensive line, no depth on defense
and a new coach who says he knows Aaron Rodgers.
-That's not what I ordered.
- I thought you could cook anything.
- Guy thinks he can turn The Bronco around, but I heard he flamed out in the big time: Seattle.
- Behind! We are behind!
Chef, hows the au jeudy?
- It's simmering?
- Thank you, Chef. Corner!
- Yes? You know, Russ, you might get further with people if you stopped acting so...extra all the time.
- Heard, Chef.
- Hey man, uh, look we made another mistake in the bread zone.
- What's up, Da Bronco?
- Ugh, this guy.
- Calm down, service isn't for another two hours.
- Two minutes, Coach. People are already lined up.
- 10, 9, 8...
- Third round, 5-foot NUTHIN. You got your bubble water and your fancy headphones. Why are you in charge of the restaurant? I should have let Marshawn run it.
- Fire! Fire everything!
- Fired? Already?
- Remember, separation comes from preparation.
- Whatever you say, Chef.
- Whatever you need, Chef.
- I want all the beef.
- The new special looks like it could be really good.
- Sorry, that's out for like 4-6 months.
- Looks like you're sticking with the usual.
- Done, Chef.
- That's it?
- Well, we couldn't finish it all so I settled for three.
[bell dings]
-How are you gonna make a Bear parody and not make it about the Bears?
We're also miserable people trying to make it work in Chicago.
Smh, I hate this more than I hate the fans.
I mean...